1 euro égale une racine les billets ne
seront pas acceptés dans votre banque
mais chez 50 professionnels du parc
naturel régional de la haute vallée de
chevreuse on voulait prendre à avec
plaisir c'est une question de
renforcement de l'économie locale de
manière générale par exemple moi je vais
acheter ma baguette en racines chez chez
mon boulanger le boulanger pourrait
acheter sa farine dans dans une ferme
locale dans un moulin locale et le
payant racines et c'est comme ça qu'on
démultiplie finalement la force d'une
monnaie locale en circulaire dimanche 7
octobre la monnaie locale faisait son
lancement officiel particuliers et
professionnels étaient nombreux à venir
au mesnil saint denis pour changer leurs
euros et favoriser une économie
circulaire sa blouse que
systématiquement l'économie locale
les gens échangent entre eux à partir de
cette monnaie locale beaucoup plus qu'il
ne le ferait à partir de blanco il faut
qu'on compense un petit peu commerces
locaux donc faucon mon cabinet aussi
être un petit peu les commerçants et les
les organismes de la vallée a développé
cette molette plus que les commerçants
se sont aussi les communes qui
commencent à s'intéresser à la racine à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines le cinéma
municipal le cratère acceptent désormais
la monnaie locale toutes les
possibilités qui nous permettent de
renforcer l'activité communiquant en
tout cas de la maintenir sont mises en
oeuvre donc la racine fait partie de ces
cordes à l'arc d arnaud lechien pour
aider nos commerçants l'association
souhaite désormais étendre sa racine sur
un territoire plus large
objectif de 1000 adhérents fin 2019
contre 350 aujourd'hui